so um welcome back to the second uh uh
talk today so it's my great pleasure to
um welcome alex to marcus thank you
cheers
okay
um thank you very much for the
invitation um so i'll be talking about
deep generative models and inverse
problems um this has been what we've
been doing for the past four years um
joint work with many of my students
uh and also colleagues here in ut
so
deep generative models uh like gans
variational auto encoders
score based generators and so on are all
basically uh
in within first approximation uh
data-driven ways to learn distributions
learn data so for gans for example in
vies i just want you to think of a
generator of again as a box
that takes a low dimensional latent
space z that leaves let's say in k
dimensions and produces an output
g of z that lives in n dimensions and n
dimensions in our in our experiments
will be images uh of let's say
resolutions uh uh up to a thousand
twenty four by thousand fifty four so
this is in the mil this can be a million
or actually if it's color images it's
red green blue in channels so it's
actually three million dimensions k in
all the experiments you'll be seeing is
something going from uh
128 up to 512 and so on so this is a
function going from a low dimensional
space like 100 dimensions to a million
dimensions and
it's uh all the things you'll see uh
involve matrix multiplications and relu
activations so it's a piecewise linear
uh function
that's differentiable almost everywhere
and by the way i would love to get
questions and their options and keep
this interactive it's much more
interesting and much more fun so please
uh ask on the chat also or uh please
interrupt
so these functions are learned from
samples
so they're data-driven
uh and i want to emphasize again that
this is not a real person this is just a
generated image that was produced by
this gan when we fed in a random noise z
as an input um
and empirically these uh deep generators
have been producing amazing results uh
that have been every year uh since 2017
have been impressing me with how much
better they keep getting so at this
point they passed this what i would call
a visual turing test that you would not
be able to tell
if these images are real people or
generated images at least unless you
start very carefully examining them
and the problem that i have been working
on in my lab
is okay we have these things they can
produce
amazing samples something that i would
never think would be possible
but can we do something useful with them
other than generate fake images
and the one answer that uh you hear is
you can generate fake pictures to make
fake social media accounts and uh
nonsense applications like that and and
uh
this this actually is being done but
this is not very useful
uh so my first point uh of this talk is
that if you have a
generator trained on a data set you care
about like for example images of human
faces or images of mri scans or images
of
any type of problem really you would you
would like to solve i would like to
argue that these are actually extremely
useful they're not uh like silly and
useless just generate fake data they are
modular and differentiable priors that
learn the statistics of your data set
and they can be used
in an incredible range of applications
so that's my first position
uh specifically we're going to present a
very general framework for solving
inverse problems and i'm going to define
what that means uh and this includes uh
examples of denoising image compression
image in painting or when you have
missing data missing data completion is
a special case of uh in painting here
colorization uh which is when you have a
black and white picture you want to add
colors for an old photographs compressed
sensing which is linear inverse problems
with random gaussian measurement
matrices
uh source separation which is the family
of problems in signal processing and i
spend a lot of time on magnetic
resonance imaging because we've been
for many years trying to get mri to work
with deep genetic models and we finally
have some new results on that so there's
many many problems that i think can be
transformed by the use of deep
generators
so the talk by the way there was a talk
uh uh two weeks ago i think in simon's i
don't know if it was in this program
that was er deep generative models a new
sparsity
uh and sort of my my punchline is that
in my opinion certainly deep generators
are the new sparse so they're going to
be extremely uh impactful i think in all
the applications where [ __ ] has been
used
uh so
uh this is the outline of my talk so
there's a general framework uh that we
call csgm so this was published in icml
2017 and it's a general framework of
solving inverse problems if you have a
pre-trained generator on like on a type
of data set you care about so i'll be
spending some time explaining this
general framework
uh
and it's an unsupervised way to solve
inverse problems and that's very
important because there's a lot of other
techniques uh that say okay you want to
reconstruct uh an image just go from
measurements train a neural network that
takes measurements as an input spits out
an image as an output and this is not
that and we will be comparing to these
standard uh much more well-known methods
there's also some interesting theory
because i understand this is mostly a
theory crowd so csgm uh this method you
can actually provide some guarantees
that are essentially generalizations of
the compressed sensing uh guarantees uh
that you get uh in uh you know uh in
standards uh
restrict eigenvalue conditions and
distribute isometries and so on so we're
going to see that
uh there the theory for inverting
generative models in general has seen a
lot of work in the last three years
i'll talk briefly about this very nice
paper by handen voloninsky which
studied the optimization problem that
arises in the csgm framework
and was able to establish theoretical
results in some some nice cases when the
generator has random independent weights
and
since that we had the paper uh in
europe's 2019 where we got some
improvement over this paper but not with
gen with gradient descent and even more
recently the scala quesada were able to
actually show that even with gradient
descent it is possible to
invert generators when you're solving
specifically as i said again this
problem for random weights under even
slightly uh more uh
general conditions so i'll talk about
this uh
line of work a little bit
uh and if people are familiar with all
this and they want me to go faster
please do let me know if people are not
familiar at all and have questions again
please do ask me um
okay room is generally not familiar but
uh yeah what's that oh in generally not
assuming not not
too much familiarity okay
agree so the last things i want to talk
about if i have time is um there's a new
algorithmic idea that expanded the csgm
framework and we call it intermediate
layer optimization so i will show how
this this is a new way of optimizing the
latent space of generators and it gets
very good results
uh
but the theory of it is quite limited at
this point so there's quite wide open
opportunity i think for theory there
and finally i'll talk uh very briefly
about our latest paper in europe's 21 uh
just accepted where we do
mri so we were able to get the first
results for mri using generators
so and if we have more time i could show
more things like fairness for inverse
problems but i doubt we will but you can
ask me at the end
so
here is the punch line immediately just
to show you the results i was giving a
talk at michigan so my host vijay here
um i went to his website i downloaded
his photograph and this is a 225 by 25
image i also removed a big chunk of
pixels in the center uh so i'm going to
show you the application of our of our
algorithm directly on this image so
we're going to do two things we're going
to do super resolution so we'll go in
1024 by 1024 and then we'll also do in
painting so we're going to complete all
those pixels missing in and the way
we're going to do that is we're going to
take a pre-trained generator that has
been trained on human faces but has
never been used for in painting for
example or super resolution and we're
going to guide the latent space of that
generator to produce an image that
agrees with vga's
pixels
when we have observations so this was
the result using our csgm method
and you can see this is a very nice
1024x24 image it knows the statistics of
human faces so it kind of completes it
nicely
but
you may notice a few things it doesn't
perfectly match in the observations for
example
and also you may notice that this
actually is a white guy whereas uh vijay
is not right so you can also see the
the
pre the bias of the generator when it is
imposing its own prior because it has
been trained with predominantly white
people in the in this dataset so you can
see immediately many of the problems uh
arising
after we use this intermediate layer
optimization idea as we optimize not
only the first latent space but also we
optimize the first layers one and two we
get this reconstruction which is
slightly better trying to fit better in
our data and if we go layers one through
four we get this reconstruction
uh and this reconstruction i think is
pretty good because you could probably
recognize vijay uh from this image if
you know uh who he is and there are a
few artifacts you may notice i assume
you can see my point there also
yeah we can see it well yeah great great
so you can see there's a few artifacts
here that perhaps can be improved
further but ilo
is actually able to produce very very
good
results for missing data
and uh it has been trained as i said
we're just using style gun 2 off the
shelf but we're we're modifying the way
we use style gun 2 to do in painting for
example
so
um let's get into the framework in
general now
so linear inverse problems
can be written in general in this way uh
is there a question
no no okay great great so do you
interrupt we can uh get questions thanks
[Music]
great
so um the general setting is like this
x-star is an unknown vector right these
are the pixels of the image uh we want
to reconstruct in our case the the
pixels the all the pixels of this
unknown image right
so x star is is the unknown vector we
want to reconstruct but we don't get to
look at x star
we get to observe measurements y
where y is a times x star possibly plus
notes right so we're in this classical
uh setting
uh and uh the very interesting and
important thing is that x star lives in
n dimensions which is high dimensions
when the number of measurements is
smaller than the dimension uh
uh of uh that you're exploring right so
you may have m noisy linear observations
of an unknown vector and your goal is to
reconstruct x star and of course this is
impossible right because it's an
ill-posed problem there are many
possible x-star vectors that explain the
measurements since we have m linear
equations and we have n unknowns and n
is more than m
and this is of course the classical
setting in high dimensional statistics
where the number of parameters is bigger
than the number of samples so the way we
deal with this in compressed sensing and
so on is we must make an assumption so
the assumption is that x star the
unknown vector has some structure right
and the classical structure that has
been used is that x star is sparse so it
has only a few non-zero entries and then
there is a lot of zeros right so if you
assume that this vector has only let's
say k non zeros
uh then you can develop the rich theory
of compressed sensing which says you can
reconstruct when m is smaller than n in
fact where m is something like k log n
uh
right
and the my talk in my framework is
saying okay this is great but now we're
going to forget about sparsity and we're
going to change it and say that x star
is in near the range of a pre-trained
generator a pre-trained generator is a
neural network that somebody gives me
right
and uh and i want to use that as a
problem and actually
people proved recently that this uh
structural assumption is strictly more
general than sparsity so i'm going to
talk about that in a bit
so the general setup for linear inverse
problems as you may know is that you're
observing noisy linear equations
um you could do something like this
you're going to say i would like to find
an x that explains the measurements
right
so um this is exactly fitting this but
also i have a regularizer here that
rewards a natural structure in x right
so in the classical sparsity setting uh
the regularizers we use is the l1
regularizer which rewards sparsity as is
well known as and this leads to a
reconstruction algorithm that's called
the lasso or
you can reward sparsity in a basis and
known basis like for example the dct
basis or the wavelet basis and so on
uh but instead of doing that the csgm
framework is going to do this
this instead it's going to optimize over
the latent space of a generator so
there's what is given to you now is a
function g of z
uh
that is that is going from a k
dimensional uh
uh low dimensional space z to a high
dimensional uh
output space x and we are trying to
search only over vectors that are
realizable by this generator to match
the measurements so this is called the
csgm framework
you can think of this
as a special case of this very general
framework if you make the regularizer
say
okay if you step outside the range of
the generator you're going to pay
infinite
penalty and you are uniform over the
range of the generator if you if you
make this regularizer here you're going
to end up in this uh in this setting
which is a cs gm set and of course the
most important
question here is is this a good
generator is it modeling the structure
of my data
is this making sense
okay
so
we have one question yep yes
sorry minor clarification so this
minimization problem for csgm can this
be solved efficiently
great question inferior in practice
maybe anything
in practice yes in theory uh
we're trying to figure it out uh and
that's one of the most important
research directions that uh that uh i'm
i'm interested in so yes in so by the
way okay great question so this problem
is a non-convex optimization problem
because gfc is a crazy neural network
right so in fact in our eurips i think
20 paper uh we proved that it's np hard
to solve this and unsurprisingly if g
has more than three layers which is
pretty pretty reasonable both so yes in
general this is a hard problem uh
remarkably empirically when we take g of
z to be style gun 2 or dc gun which are
real generators
we can solve this problem and that's how
you saw these results before that's what
i'm actually doing so i am actually
getting something very good now how do i
know i'm actually solving it optimally
uh i don't but what i do know is i can
start with a g of z that is realizable
and then i can solve it in the case
where i know this is possible this
should go to zero and then i do see that
it does so go to zero empirically so
empirically we do find that this works
uh theoretically um the work by paul
hand and voloninsky was able to
establish that gradient descent provably
solves it when the generator has random
weights
but the generator has to have every
layer significantly expanding
if every layer is not significantly
expanding it's open
and the real generators do not have
every layer significant extent so that's
so thank you for your question you
already yeah yeah yes so that's that's
one of the major conversations very good
so
uh so the general idea is sparsity and
basis is a decent model for natural
images as we said
and uh now we have much better
data-driven models uh to get structure
in high dimensions and we call them deep
generated models
and the key idea is replaced every time
you have a paper or you see a paper that
says oh i assume a vector sparse replace
it with x's in the range of a
pre-trained generator glz and now you
have a new problem and you can have a
lot of fun
and if you have a good generator
you will actually get very very good
results in practice
uh
an interesting fact recently proved by
akshay kamath sushrut uh karma khan and
eric price
is that this assumption is a proper
generalization of this assumption
because they were able to construct
generative models that have i believe
three layers if i remember correctly and
producer in the range all case parts
vectors
so assuming that your vector is k sparse
is a special case of assuming it comes
from a generator with a polynomial
basically polynomial size so actually
depth three i believe was the their
construction so it is actually
mathematically a proper generalization
so
the key issue is how do we solve inverse
problems and the answer is what i showed
already we minimizing the latent space
so very quickly just to show you
empirical results
uh we have the pre-trained generator i
want to emphasize again just to be clear
that g of z has some weights here for
style gun 2 uh nvidia trained this on on
hundreds of hours of data and they spend
enormous amounts of money an enormous
compute to get the weights of g of z
we're not messing with the internal
structure of g of z we're only messing
with the input
vector the latent vector and we're
trying to get g of z to match my
observations and in this case this is
the inversion problem which is just uh
my picture from my website right
and you can also use this directly for
denoising you can take my picture from
my website add noise and solve exactly
the same thing this is called also
projecting on the range of a generator
how do you do it as i said the way you
do everything in deep learning is you
define a loss which is a differentiable
function of z right you start with a
random z you're going to get a random
phase
then you compute the gradient of the l2
this is l2 norm here the l2 loss of gfc
minus the target image which is my face
and you do gradient descent in g of z
this is a non-convex problem in fact in
picard as we said but luckily in this
particular case you get this guy
now this guy kind of looks like me
but it's not really me right which means
that now there are two possible things
either i am in the range but uh i failed
to find it
or this is the best person that uh the
the closest projection to my face i i
don't know in this case because i don't
know how to solve this problem i suspect
it is because this is one of the closest
style guns you can produce for my face i
don't expect it's because of the
optimization uh and the way we solve it
you have a question just in a moment yes
just to make sure that i understand the
ultimate goal so so this
giving again the whole image
like you've done here is just the
starting point of what you might
ultimately want to do right which is
like i give you only uh a few linear
measurements of the image or something
like that is that the right intuition
exactly okay and you're saying that even
even here if i give it the whole image i
do okay but not that great
yes yes yes here i am basically limited
by the expressive capabilities of the
generator and and the generator here is
style gantu which is a very good one but
it doesn't have me or
or you or most real people in it's in
exactly in this range at least that's
what i believe uh and
this can be directly used for denoising
because i could be giving x1 plus noise
and do the same thing but we're going to
see this is a very general thing that
can solve all linear inverse problems in
fact all in response with differentiable
forward operators but yes this is just
the beginning so
uh the next by the way we proposed this
uh in 2017 and many other people uh
independently of us propose this also
because it's a very natural thing to do
of course
now to get a little more interesting now
we have in painting how do we solve in
paint well in painting can be written as
y observations these are the
observations is ax
where a is a matrix that has rows that's
the subset of the identity right so now
i can solve exactly the same thing but
i'm changing my loss to be a times g of
z so a the measurements of the generated
image minus the measurements that i
observe here i don't observe x1 which
would be the full picture here i observe
ax1 which corresponds to only the
observation again i do gradient descent
in the latent space of this pre-trained
generator and i get this image
this is by the way with an older
generator now so these are all the
results that's why they they are lower
resolution uh but it's a pretty good in
painting you may notice the the mouth
doesn't perfectly match so of course you
can do extra tricks you can take this
completion put it here and blur the
surroundings to make it better in
painting and so on but i'm not
interested in that i'm just trying to
tell you that just vanilla doing this
already produces pretty good results
this is the csgm framework
and you can also use it for a super
resolution or d blurring for example
in this case you observed a blurred
image and this blurred image
is constructed by convolving a clean
image with a known kernel a gaussian
kernel here so again you just do the
same thing but now a is a the blurring
matrix the convolution with a gaussian
operator and here i assume i know the
measurement matrix if you don't know the
forward operator it's actually
interesting to do to do this kind of
generative modeling uh inverse problems
with an unknown name it's it's i haven't
seen any papers on this yet but i'm sure
it's going to be very fruitful
in this case you just no way you do
gradient descent again and you get this
image which is a pretty plausible uh
deep learning
uh so this is the general uh setting so
csgm says do gradient is sending the
latent space to satisfy the measurements
and the thing is you do you obtain
useful gradients because everything is
differentiable right so back propagation
is key here because you're back
propagating through the generator and
the forward operator and the thing to
realize is that it you don't need a to
be a matrix a can be any forward
operator
even in neural network
and then you can still run this
procedure and and uh people have used
this to solve phase retrieval with a
generative prior uh which is an example
of a non-linear inverse problem so this
is a very general uh idea is this making
sense
okay
great
uh i want to emphasize again that there
are many other methods of solving
inverse problems that do not use the
csgn framework the most standard is what
i call supervised end-to-end methods
train a neural network to go from
measurements to reconstructions
do it on a gazillion uh measured images
and you're going to get a very good
reconstruction actually better than this
okay so the supervised methods are
typically better than our framework
but our message is that
if you're if there is any uncertainty
whatsoever in the forward operator
uh or if there's any variability in the
structure of the of your inverse problem
end-to-end methods are very fragile to
any variability basically
and there are other techniques too
called cycle gun ambient gun and so on
we have a survey that we try to
summarize the methods but the the
general idea here i hope is very clear
and the other thing to emphasize again
is the generator was trained here on
clean images it doesn't know anything
about in painting or super resolution
whereas the forward operator is
representing the type of corruptions you
have so we're completely separating the
statistics of the images we care about
with the met with the process of
measuring them the physics of measuring
them for example um
whereas all end-to-end methods are going
to bake in the same network both the
statistics of images and the forward
measuring process so that's one of the
most important differences now on theory
side i know this is a theory crowd so
i'll tell you a few things that we can
prove so why our measurements is the
original unknown magic star plus noise
noisy linear equations and let's say you
could solve this problem
uh
then our
basic theorem is that if your
measurement matrix is random and
gaussian
uh where the number of measurements is k
d log n now k is the latent space of our
generator so it's something like 100 or
512 d is the depth
of the generator and n is the ambient
dimension which is like a million but we
only have logarithmic dependence
then the reconstruction that you're
going to get using your z hat so this is
the reconstruction you get g of z hat
minus the unknown ground true
is going to be within a constant factor
from this thing now what is this thing
this is the best possible reconstruction
your generator can produce right you
cannot compute this because you don't
have x star right this is the inversion
but you don't have an inversion you have
corrupt you have corrupted linear
equations so the main point is this is
basic measuring the quality of your
generator if this is big then you need
to throw away the generator and buy a
bigger one right but if this is small by
doing gradient design the latent space
to satisfy the measurements you're going
to get a constant factor approximation
now the thing that many theorists should
jump up here they should immediately
tell me this is impossible because you
have noisy linear equations so i hid
here
a constant times the autonomous of the
noise so that's that's the there is an
additive term of course that depends on
the noise
uh uh and if you want the exact theorem
there's also a stronger result that says
even if you don't fully solve this but
you solve this within an additive or
epsilon you can also get the
epsilon here to within another constant
um so this is kind of the type of
results we get and the most interesting
thing is that the measurement uh some
complexity
depends on the generator uh a more
general result that we were able to
prove these are all from 2017 is that if
uh if you have any generator that is lip
sheets so i don't uh model it here so
this in this case by the way i was
modeling it as a relu piecewise linear
network right so matrix multiplication
really matrix multiplication really
times uh for d layers
in the more general case if you have an
ellipses function generator uh the
number of measurements scales like that
so k is the latent dimension and log l
uh is the l is the lipschitz constant we
expect the ellipses constant to be
exponential in depth
at least in the worst case
uh and therefore these results are kind
of kind of scaling in the similar way so
is this making sense any questions on
this
yeah sorry i think i just don't
understand the basic setup so this is
this is
for this is if you actually manage to
solve the minimization problem like
there's no
it's not like you're it's not like you
know that gradient doesn't gives you
this this is just if you if i magically
give you an oracle that solves this
thing exactly yes z-hat is the magical
solution and i say
yeah that's a very good point exactly so
on the optimization we'll talk in a
minute but yeah
anything else
okay yeah so this is the information
theoretic uh
uh
oh i see the microphone is moving
but
yeah we'll we'll um i'm just passing
around when people have questions
okay yeah i see a very small screen but
okay very good so uh yes perfect remark
indeed this is if you could solve the
problem exactly
uh now the theory of how you so we'll
talk how you prove this
and
what is the i don't know if you're
familiar with the theory of compressed
sensing and rip and so on but it's kind
of building on that
but now the set of natural signals is no
longer the set of signals that are
sparse but rather the set of signals
that can be produced by this pre-trained
generator
so the rip property for a measurement
matrix for compressed sensing is
basically saying that all sparse vectors
are far from the null space of
measurement
here to establish these results we
define what we call a set restricted
eigenvalue condition shrek
that is asking for the differences
of pairs of generated images to be far
from the null space
so this turns out to be the correct
generalization
of rip in the case where uh the
generated uh the natural vectors are not
sparse but rather come from a generic
and the key lemma can you can you remind
us what rip is
yes rip the restricted isometry property
is uh is the key property that people
use for compressed sensing for a matrix
it says that a uh
x1
the l2 norm so i get a little bit of
echo but
is is less than or equal to 1 plus
epsilon
[Music]
x1
and is greater or equal to 1 minus
epsilon
l two norm of x two
of x one sorry
uh for all so if you had this property
that would be an isometry so it's
impossible to get this property if a
it has a null space right because there
will be vectors that are not zero that
will have a x one is zero so you want
this to hold for all vectors x one that
are k stars
so if you have this property you can
reconstruct sparse vector it's a
classical
um theoretical result in the theory of
compressed sense and we are generalizing
this uh from sparse vectors to vectors
created by a generator so this is kind
of the
theorem makes sense yeah thanks
thank you thank you okay
so
then the way these proofs work
is that i'm just very briefly going to
talk about the the proving technology i
have 15 minutes right so
yeah okay 15 minutes yeah yeah so the
question here is how to bound the metric
entropy of the generator range so you
think of the generator range these are g
of z's every generated image
as z is ranging in z here is is going to
cover rk or you can think of it covering
the unit ball in rk basically uh you
know we can compactify it quite easily
so for for practical purposes think that
z lives on the unit sphere in rk it
passes through this uh new crazy neural
network it produces a crazy manifold in
our end and we want to bounce the metric
entropy of the of the of this set right
so the way we do that is we make an
epsilon net we want to make an epsilon
here but we don't know anything about
this crazy function so we basically need
to get a bound
on how close these points can be
so that these points have form an
epsilon net and the distortion in
distance in the worst case is the
ellipses constant really right so you
basically make this uh
set the points sufficiently dense so
that even after they're multiplied by
l distortion due to this unknown crazy
mapping you're still going to get an
epsilon net here and that's what's
controlling your union bound and gives
you this uh this mk logan bound here if
you are familiar with compressed sensing
theory this makes sense if you're not uh
don't worry about it and we can't take
it offline
so
the other question is that that has been
brought up is okay you said you can
solve this
uh and empirically
it works remarkably but can we have any
theory for how to solve this
and this is uh the the remarkable
results started with hand and voroninsky
in cold 2018
said that if this generator has two
properties if the weights are random iid
gaussian for example uh
and the extra property is that each
layer is log k factor bigger compared to
the previous layer so if the first layer
of the generator has dimension k
the second layer of the generator must
have k lock k
and the third layer must have k lok k
square right
and so on
so they say if the generator has random
weights in each of those layers with
relu activations right so this is still
a crazy non-convex optimization problem
but remarkably they were able to prove
that the loss function this loss
function
this is l2 nor
has only two
minima the correct global minimum and
another funny point that appears
and they're able to show with gradient
descent with the correct initialization
that basically gradient descent probably
solves this problem with high
probability over the weights so i found
this quite a remarkable uh result in
optimization
and
then then they have been able to
generalize this and expand it for
example in phase retrieva which is a
non-linear forward operator and again
they were able to prove that gradient
descent but now a is a is a non-linear
forward operator
it's still gradients and still solves a
problem if the generator has random
weights and uh there is sufficient
expansivity or expansion i don't like
expansion because it might have expanded
graphs but you know it's kind of the
word of how much the generator is
expanding in each layer
now unfortunately
real generators do not have any
expansion they do not have locate oh i
forgot to say uh more recently uh the
scala acetal were able to relax this
result into constant
so they need like a constant factor
expansion in every layer and they were
able as far as i understand to
strengthen the concentration results
that are used in these papers to get the
constant expansion as opposed to
logarithmic this is a very recent paper
i think it's a one year old and
unfortunately
real generators do not have expansion in
every layer they do have expansion
they keep going but near the end before
you get to the pixels there is a
contracting layer so this theory doesn't
apply to real generators and it is an
open problem uh to the best of my
knowledge if you can prove something
about the optimization with random
weights if there is at least let's say
one layer that is contracting
uh is this making sense
can you tell us a little bit more about
what do you mean this assumption about
having random weights
yeah so so so you start with a vector z
you multiply by a matrix w one times z
and w one is a matrix that produces a
bigger vector right so if this vector is
dimension k this vector is k log k
now w1 is assumed to have random
independent gaussian weight zero mean
variance one i think or something
uh and then uh then you you pass this
through a low activation
so you pass a relu activation to this
vector
and then you multiply by another matrix
w2 and you get another vector that's k
log k square
and it keeps going like that
uh and i think the result uh is not
sensitive on depth
i don't think they i think they can do
it for any constant depth they don't
need the depth to depend on k and so on
in practice depth is something like
eight like the generators we use have
depth five to eight or or maybe ten so
it's not that the depth is is huge
and you see this is now a non-convex
function a piecewise linear
crazy function of z right
yeah and so this w1 and w2 with a random
we assume they're random all the weights
have to be random and independent in the
in this in this generator and every
layer has to be log k factor bigger than
the previous layer
and that's that's what their result is
to the best of my understanding and as i
said they were able to like the skeleton
and his co-authors
were able to
reduce lock k to constant i don't know
what constant uh actually but i don't
think it's a small cons but it is a
constant factor expansion of every layer
but as i'm saying the real generators
that we use
do not have expansivity in every layer
they the last layer seems to have a
contraction so that's one of the
that's one of the limitations of the
theory so it's an open problem to prove
it if there is a single layer contracts
but i think it's very interesting if you
care about optimization this probably
one of the most interesting results and
some of the most interesting open
problems too
very good any other questions on that
yep yeah so
oh yes
just a small question why is the
contraction layer needed like will you
get just bad results if you don't have
that
um you're asking why it's needed in real
generators or why it's needed in the
theory uh in real generators
yeah
in real generators what is happening is
i think it is needed because the layer
before the last one produces something
like uh a
a very high number of channels so in in
you know in real convolution on neural
networks there is three dimensions right
so there is the the key thing you need
is really a large number of channels so
that it's not that it is a thousand by
thousand by three it is more like uh you
know 50 by 50 but times 256.
so the the contraction happens because
you have a lot of latent uh channels and
you produce only three channels in the
end red green and blue and if you don't
have a lot of channels in the
intermediate uh you we don't know how to
make generators that work
so i think you need it in practice yes
any other question yeah yeah we have i
have a question
um here you
minimize the l2 loss right and the
subject to z belongs to some say
subspace
yes um i think
in the compressor sensing the l2 the
minimization in theory um may not
outperform say other matter like the
density selector
here i'm i was curious is there a
version of a density selector here
or does it work better
yeah so
we have we have tried this this method
we have compared it with uh lasso so we
haven't compared with transit selector
but i can show you comparisons to lasso
i think but we are we are using 10 times
10x
better than lasso and i doubt dancing
selector was you know
10 times better so i think i have those
results
um
yeah
so
i'm showing so here is the
reconstruction so we're here we're
valuing the number of measurements we're
running this on uh on images of human
faces
and what you can see here is our results
these are our results with basically
their equivalent there's a little
regularization here but it doesn't
matter
uh and what what you can see is that the
reconstruction error per pixel we get
when we have a hundred measurements
uh is matching the performance of lasso
with a thousand measurements
this is using lasso in the dct and in
the wavelet domain uh you can use
more learned bases you can use of course
better optimizations but i doubt you
will be able to get maybe you'll be able
to get i think you know 500 measurements
like half the measurements from lasso
for the same quality right so
here we get
about 10x like shockingly better
performance until a point actually and
this is another interesting remark to
emphasize after this point we're no
longer getting better five beyond 500
measurements
our method does not improve whereas
lasso and sparsity-based methods are
outperforming us in this regime and now
you need now is an important question to
realize why this is happening in this
regime after 500 measurements you have
basically reached the representation
capability of your generator if you're
going to have more than 500 measurements
you need to throw away the generator and
buy a bigger one that has a bigger
latent dimensional space so it can
represent it can benefit from from the
more measurements right so the
representation capability of the
generator depends on how noisy or how
many or how few measurements you're
expecting your problem to have
am i am i answering your question yeah
yeah
yeah yeah it's very interesting yeah if
the number of measurements is very high
then
we should probably apply
lasso from this picture right of course
of course of course in in if you're in a
very high measurement regime absolutely
so so just uh just to briefly show you
some
and wrap it up i think i have like a few
minutes we have been trying to use this
now for mri so i'll just quickly show
you results on mri
so uh because i'm very happy we finally
managed to finish this so so we were
able to train a generator uh for uh
mri images and uh i'll show you the
results quickly uh this is our paper
that uh sorry this is neurips21 so very
recent
uh and we trained the first deep
generative model for clinical mri data
and we use the facebook fast mri data
set which is a well-known challenge that
many many teams are working on
the results very quickly is that we
match the performance of supervised deep
learning techniques so people have built
very very sophisticated supervised good
learning techniques supervised means you
go from measurements to reconstruction
for example and when we are in
distribution we match them
but when we when for example the
measurement process changes because for
example the scanner changes or the
process that you measure uh the case the
case space changes we significantly
outperform basically all known methods
using our generative model
and we mostly help perform i say here
supervised methods when there are
anatomy changes for example we tried
training on brains and reconstructing
knees or abdomens and usually we do
better than supervised methods also
trained on brains and tried on knees
so we also did a preliminary
evaluation with radiologists and our
reconstructions are ranked as higher
diagnostic quality in a blind evaluation
test that we did by three experts so we
basically showed them a lot of images
and we said do you like this image
better or this image in this image and
they didn't know which one is ours and
which one is the previous state of the
art uh by the way sparsity-based are are
usually not competitive with with these
methods so the results here quickly
you're reconstructing brains here
this is the acceleration so here you may
spend 45 minutes in a scanner uh you
know and this is uh 3x acceleration 4x
acceleration 6x acceleration eight times
and so on so you may spend up 10 minutes
or five minutes in a scanner if you're
in very high accelerations which is a
huge thing right because spending 45
minutes in the scanner we're spending
five minutes in scanner is a huge thing
both for the patient and also for the
utilization of the scan
so the quality of our method here is
shown here this is psnr and you can see
that in very high accelerations we are
significantly outperforming
all known methods
and similarly here if you change the way
you measure the measurement structure in
k space
there's a huge gap of our methods to all
known methods sparsity-based methods are
shown here in in actually in red
so
sparsity-based methods here are are okay
but deep learning end-to-end methods are
are better in some cases we lose we
typically lose in the
low accelerations exactly the same as
high measurements right
so in high measurements uh wavelet
methods exactly as before are the best
right if you have if you have a lot of
measurements parsit is fine actually
but we want to accelerate the running
times and for some anatomies we are
matching or slightly losing uh compared
to uh you know uh modl and end to
environment which is very powerful
methods so
here are reconstructions if you're into
mri we could dive into them but my
colleagues tell me that these are base
this is our column
and they tell me that they are
equal uh basically about the same
quality as the best deep learning
techniques out there uh i mean you have
to zoom in to look at these things but
i'll be glad to talk about it but i'll
wrap up now and i'll take questions if
people want to see more about this so
just to very quickly give you the
conclusions
uh
so sorry let me find my slide here
okay
so conclusions generative models are
powerful data-driven priors and they're
very modular uh because you can
back-prop through them basically open
research questions as we said open
solving inverse problems uh and proofs
for optimization is interesting as we
discussed
imposing physical constraints on the
generated data is something that many
people who solve pdes and have universe
problems for example that come from pdes
they want to add extra constraints i
think it's a very interesting open area
robustness to errors and corruptions
again uh in compressed sensing people
have studied this but we very recently
published a paper on how do you do
compress sensing when you have
generative models but you have corrupted
data
there's a fairness issue as you saw from
the bias in the race so uh we have a
recent paper on that uh that you know i
didn't have time to talk about and we
have a recent paper on using it on mri
that seems to be uh i hope that we'll be
able to get it to be clinically useful
with more research
if you care about my papers and so on
you can follow me on twitter and find my
webpage and these are the links just to
put them on the slide
in case anybody wants to find them
these are the papers i talked about and
thank you very much i'll take questions
okay thank you yeah let's have a couple
of questions and then we might um have a
discussion around there as we would if
you're really in physically here yeah
thank you so much alex i'm here hold on
here i really really enjoyed your talk
uh so i had a
perhaps philosophical question so when
you're using this for mris this is going
to somewhat bias the
you know the
results towards uh the things that
neural net has seen so what if for
example the patient goes there and they
have some anomaly that wasn't in the
data
and this year keeps coming up with fda
approvals for neural net models and i
just wanted to know your opinion about
this alex exactly yes exactly so so
first of all the moment you have an
imposed problem right any in ill post
inverse problem you're gonna have to put
pride right so there is there's no way
around it uh mathematically to solve an
imposed interest problem without some
prior belief but generative models are
it's much harder to understand what
their prior beliefs are compared to
sparsity where you understand okay
prefers sparsity you know in wave
letters
uh empirically speaking uh so the only
answer i think that you can give in this
is empirically right so empirically uh
what we did we have tried to address
this partially
and for example here's one example
is
this is a meniscus
tear
and this is the fully sampled image and
this is the part that radiologists care
about and this part here you can see
this part zoomed in here
so again i i don't know another
ideologist obviously but they tell me
that if if you should get this image
of course you know the muscle structure
here and so on in the knee is nice but
they don't care about that they only
care about this little line here in the
center so if your algorithm hallucinates
a healthy meniscus and produces an
excellent image with excellent psnr
then it's it's it's diagnostically uh
beyond useless it's like mostly
dangerous right
so
so uh that's the thing that we have to
check uh gladly for our generator here
our generator is what's called the
score-based ncsmv2 it's basically what
we used in this paper
uh so the reconstruction we get on the
meniscus area as you can see here is
higher quality diagnostically compared
to the uh state-of-the-art methods modl
and e to evarnet and uh and i'm
emphasizing here that this is out of
distribution because this this uh all
these neural networks were trained on
brains
so i think
a healthy test to address a
great comment is if your method is
robust out of distribution then if a
patient has some strange a medical
condition then it's going to be less
likely to impose uh its own beliefs and
its own priors uh to that data set so i
think testing out of distribution
testing robustness in anatomy changes is
is a healthy a sensible test beyond of
course an ideology tests but we are
finding that
generative methods and supervised
methods are much more robust to anatomy
changes and even within the specifics of
meniscus there and so on we find that or
at least our radiologists tell us that
that it's actually better diagnosed
great thanks maybe we have time for one
more question
yeah awesome
uh how how
how bad is this uh in the theory side
how about is this um random weights
assumption like you know you don't you
don't need any such assumption like
there's not really an analogous
assumption in compressed sensing right
because sparsity is sparsity
yeah
how how important for avoiding hardness
is this like could you imagine
less could you imagine more permissive
um theorems that wouldn't require random
weights i imagine you can't have worse
case weights because of some empty
hardness but
very good question so
short answer i don't know i
when i initially saw random weights i'm
like oh but that's not the real
generator at all
but you see the saving grace in my
opinion is
if these
generators are massively over
parameterized they have like a billion
weights and you end up doing a few
gradient descent steps when you're
training them i mean i don't know you
know how few you do right depends i mean
in practice we spend days training them
but they're also massively over
parameterized so
if you take the limit that the generator
is getting more and more over
parameterized compared to the gradients
and steps we do then you're getting
closer and closer to a random network
right
so that's kind of my intuition that i
don't mind random weights anymore
because as our generators are getting
bigger i don't think we are i think
we're getting closer and closer to
random networks in some crazy way that
doesn't make sense because they're still
very good generators right whereas a
random weight generator would suck right
so uh but i think that uh if the ex the
justification is that that
the more of the parameterize you get the
the closer you get in a way to your
initialization um
i would love to get a weaker condition
you will not obviously be able to prove
it in general because we proved it
simply hard but maybe there's a much
healthier assumption uh and and also the
expansivity is is a is a huge uh
limitation of the theory
okay great thanks so let's uh thank alex
again cheers